you'll be taking on right-hander paul
blackburn
making his seventh start of the season
for the green and gold and
a pretty big start in that last time
around against the kansas city royals
pitch well
you know i don't want to call it a must
win but a very important ballgame was
able to get the w happy plane flight
trying to do what he can here against
the seattle mariner club that's been
swinging the bat fairly well
no need for a jacket strike three called
on the outside corner ty france
gets caught
two ounce nobody on here's the payoff
[Music]
seeger with a shot down the right field
line this short hops the wall
and seeger with extra bases he chugs
into second base and he slides in with a
two-out double
[Applause]
chapman's got it on the backhand
goes across the diamond in time and
seeger is stranded at second when we
come back the a's will get to work with
the bats no score
as marco is up on the mound today he's
making his 23rd start of the season
eight-game winner he ra just over four
124 in the third 95 strikeouts for mark
homes olson at 274. 36 homers 103 rbis
[Music]
that would sit high and deep to right
field bowers back bowers near the wall
and that baby's gone
got him again
37th home run that's a new career high
for matt olsen fourth time he has
homered off marco gonzalez this year
well you hang it and only will bang it
no doubt about it
swinging a miss
marco's first strike out of the night it
ends the bottom of the first
hayes an early one-nothing lead
nasty pitch by blackberry so that's out
number one here in the number five jake
powers top of the second
little more batting ninth demanding
second base abraham toro getting a
breather tonight this one
just gets away barely here comes bowers
he's on his way home and he scores
we're tied
on a ball that got away from olson by
just a matter of inches
great reaction to it you could see him
actually get down the line a little bit
further just in case something happens
and it certainly did
swinging the miss struck him out so
across the air by the athletics and it
allows the mariners to tie up the game
bottom of the second coming up i got a
1-1 ball game
[Music]
for the drive out to left fraley back in
front of the wall by the headlights
makes a catch
round number three
side retired in order and after two
we're talking
past johnny bench's record for most home
runs in a single season by a catcher and
then kyle seeger
okay this is an existing velocity
zigger's got himself his second double
of the ball game
seeger fights that one off
and uh this bean bag that finds its way
into left field that's not gonna make
the list 56 miles an hour off the bat
still counts for two bases that's right
[Music]
line drive short hop harrison flips to
first got him
nice play by harrison a little
backhanded short hop nicely done
tries to hold back but can't help
himself and there is out number two
they can pull even with the athletics of
the win
harrison first pitch swinging he reaches
forward and sends it to center marco
pretty quick and tidy one two three
bottom of the third all time going to
the fourth
can't replicate whether or not the game
is meaningful or not or there are fans
there or not
kellnick rips this to the gap
and bounces to the base of the fence
kelnix red hot september continues he
wants three he's on his way he slides in
he's out at third
he thought he was in there though he
thought he had his foot in there before
chapman was able to put the tag on him
it was a quick tag
he is safe triple
first career triple for jared kelman
and a swing
and a miss big strikeout for blackburn
and he got it
murphy strikes out
two hours
it's up to dylan moore now
delamore drive out to left field canna
can't make the catch celtic is in
fraley motors
all the way around
he scores
dylan moore off the wall has put the
meriters in front with two outs in the
top of the fourth inning
on the ground and in his center field
j.p crawford
he drives in dylan moore and the
mariners extend the lead it's
one
uh
i can't believe you didn't think of this
eric first round of goose in baseball
history
dancing rally goose that is
we'll have to
fight back tonight
that one has driven to center and it's
hit well kellnick back held it near the
wall and
that baby's gone
i'll tell you that is much
much needed not only for marty but i
think for this open offense here in this
stage of the ball game this stage of the
season right now
marco trying to strand two here in the
fourth inning two outs two on the two
two
oh j.p crawford
with a lasso job at shortstop how did he
wrap that up for out number three marco
likes it yeah
he bet
[Applause]
oh swinging after a high limb and
harrison
is down on strikes marco retires his
side in order for the third time in five
frames
marco trying to work around a lead off
walk first walk tonight
[Music]
long run france france makes the catch
he covers the ground and puts a bow on
six strong from marco his third straight
quality start
two ounce two on go ahead run at the
plate bottom of the eighth inning
and he got him
right down broadway and chapman can't
sniff it
joe romo taking over for the a's
as crawford
high towering fly ball
and that's a fair ball and gone
j.p crawford keeps that fair
and blasts it well beyond the fence
little insurance for the mariners number
nine for the mariners shortstop and it's
5-2 mariners round the runner at first
two outs bottom nine the 1-1
jammed him popped it up
seeger is right there and the mariners
have taken the first two in oakland they
win tonight in nine
you